so hilf dir gott so hilf mir gott
herzlichen glückwunsch herr präsident
joe biden ist der abschnitt 56 die
präsidentenzeremonie
ist
dies ist amerikas tag
dies ist der tag der demokratie ein tag der geschichte
und der hoffnung
auf erneuerung und entschlossenheit
auf der
reise der präsidentschaftskandidaten
dies ist unser historischer  Moment der Krise
und Herausforderung
und Einheit ist der Weg nach vorne
und wir müssen diesen Moment als die
Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika bewältigen, wenn wir das tun,
garantiere ich Ihnen, dass wir gestern nicht scheitern werden,
wir können uns nicht als Gegner sehen,
sondern als Nachbarn, die
wir jeden behandeln können  Mit Würde und
Respekt können
wir uns zusammenschließen, das Geschrei stoppen und
den
Temperaturanstieg senken
,
aber
ich weiß, dass das Sprechen von Einheit
heutzutage für manche wie eine törichte Fantasie klingen kann.
Ich weiß, dass die Kräfte, die uns trennen,
tief und real sind,
aber ich weiß es auch  Sie sind nicht neu,
unsere Geschichte war ein ständiger Kampf
zwischen dem amerikanischen Ideal, dass wir
alle gleich geschaffen sind,
und der harten, hässlichen Realität, die Rassismus,
Nativismus, z  ar dämonisierung
hat uns schon lange auseinander gerissen fremde
meine amerikaner ich schloss den tag an
dem ich begann
mit dem heiligen schwur vor gott und
euch allen
ich gebe euch mein wort ich werde immer auf gleicher höhe
mit euch sein
ich werde die verfassung verteidigen ich werde
unsere demokratie verteidigen
Ich werde Amerika verteidigen und werde
euch allen alles geben,
was ich tue, in euren Diensten
behalten Atlantischer Sultan Alistair Toon
[Musik]